yeah I know and welcome to this video
which looks a bit different obviously
but I thought for a book review this is
maybe an interesting way of doing and to
actually have the book in front of me
not just the computer screen with some
some chess pieces so we're going to
cover lots of ground here table books
here so let's start it's a selection of
books mostly mostly from 2017 this year
or maybe 2016 some of them I think I
also should add that I'm going to show
some books that are older but there are
favorites of mine and they kind of fit
into the general theme let's say
especially here with the first book that
I'm going to show again I have a look at
this this is the first book Judah Brian
I hope I'm not completely killing the
pronunciation there the chess
revolutionary by Jimmy Adams if you see
when this is like I mean this is a book
you know this is not some something that
you can like I don't know we do one
handed it's really really a big big
heavy book so how many pages is that I
think it's close to 900 let's have a
look it's 800 876 yeah okay so each dude
it's absolutely huge so what is it all
about and who is the author Jimmy Adams
as we learn from from the back here of
the book is a freedom master and
prolific chest author he has written a
couple of books already on chess history
both cyka taught chigorin and this is
really it's a fantastic book I mean I
have to say that with 880 pages
obviously did not read all of it I read
most of the tech staff to say and look
through a couple of games this is a book
and that is about a player that is
mostly known now it
is yeah for the invention or he's the
name sake of the brayer variation in the
reuleaux past I have a chessboard here
and this is mostly for the later books
but for those of you are not instantly
familiar with the brayer variation of
the Ring this is going to be the ruler
pass and we follow the main line to the
day that's the main line and after age
three there is this move Knight to be
eight which is yet the brayer variation
at the time and we're talking about yeah
the the start of the 20th century this
was completely out of this world yet to
redevelop let's say undeveloped unite in
order to get it to a better square your
d7 this is just one of Breyers
inventions and he's got them many more
to his credit some of them really didn't
didn't stick so much till today but the
bray is probably the most respectable
opportunity at this point nowadays not
that the other ones of barristers that
is it's an absolute mainline and widely
accepted us perfectly okay for for the
black player so this is how we know
brayer today he was an extremely
interesting character I have to say I
did not really know much about him
before before getting this book I only
knew that okay he is the namesake of the
bravery and
I knew that he died very very young at
age 28 tragically he had a heart
condition that also influenced his whole
life he always yeah he never was
physically perfectly fit always suffered
from some sort of illness due to that an
extremely interesting character we learn
a lot about his life and his chess
inventions of course it is totally
staggering that brayer only joined a
chess club at age 17 in Budapest in
Hungary he was Hungarian and and no 17
enjoyed the Chess Club in roughly two
years he got to a strong master strength
and competed in international
tournaments only to die like nine years
later and in this span of nine years or
ten years he produced an astounding
amount of chess chess pros he's written
numerous articles he annotated his games
in this book there are 280 if I'm not
mistaken if I was taken or not off by a
lot I think roughly 280 office games and
it's it's fantastic because it's
annotated by Bray himself but also by
his contemporaries like they are here
for example I'm just opening a random
page we have some games with rotations
by Greenfeld yeah at the time the
criminal defense was also invented by
maracas see nowadays known for the
maracas see bind we have commentary here
annotations by but article by already
yeah it fits fantastic
and it's all very very nicely written
office name some of the contemporary
annotations are not correct by modern
standards where this is clearly the case
so where there's a clear mistake in them
it is oftentimes pointed out by the
author and given in brackets like okay
this is a contemporary but we know
nowadays that this and that is the case
this is I think quite helpful however
you have to do it you know in a somewhat
yeah considerate amount otherwise you're
killing the original text and I think
they did a good job here well Jimmy
Adams did a good job too not yeah like
correct every single thing that there is
I mean there are problems with old old
annotations by modern standards some
some things nowadays are like refuted by
computers for example but also there are
some opening some opening a notation
that are just not on modern standards
it's just like it's like almost 100
years ago so we have to see that we are
standing on the shoulders of giants and
these were the giants that invented a
modern modern chess in a way of modern
approaches modern ideas here this is
also one of Breyers interesting
inventions Queenie of three and in the
in the King's gambit this is really not
a good line so at the time and we see
the original notation
with an exclamation exclamation mark and
so these of course have taken with with
a grain of salt it's great if you're
interested in chess history and you're
interested in learning about how chess
actually became what it is nowadays it's
it's fantastic it's just it's not the
kind of book that you take with you and
take with you on on let's say under me
on the bus or something and you just
like you should take with you and read
yeah it's really something to enjoy on a
real chess board and yeah it's it's
great it just it's just enormous in I'm
going to go to a tournament tomorrow and
maybe I have to check my luggage you
have got some some space space I will
take this with me and read it a little
bit more when either way a really really
great book to recommend speaking about
books about chess history and historical
figures I thought I felt it is
appropriate to mention some books that
are amongst the favorite of mine I'm
going to put that aside they are all a
little bit older but it's still
fantastic stuff so one of my absolute
favorite books about yeah chess history
in a way and historical chess figure is
this one meant Larson's best games this
book has been around for a while and has
been somewhat modified over the years
this is all written by Ben Larson
himself and he studies here he would
look at the chapter I hope that really
works with the video he's showing his
whole career starting in the in the late
50s and so on and then over to the 60s
you know the match against Fisher and so
on it's a it's a the whole whole story
and this book I think was originally
released in
a TSM and then it got somewhat extended
later with some articles this is from
1994 I think sorry from from 2014 from
2014 when they added some articles about
Fischer meeting about last meeting
fission all written by banana of course
so it's kind of an extended edition if
you want this is also fantastic book
this is more about if you compare that
to the Braille book this is more about
about the game stem I mean there is
there is text about the child emergence
and you get a good insight into Lawson
but it's more about the games and Lawson
was a creative genius and if you really
had fantastic fantastically inventive
games and what is really great about
this book and it's something that I
don't completely know about is and how
did that came to came to be is the the
quality of the annotation is fantastic
if this is really what Lawson originally
did like in 1980 or so without the help
of a computer this is mind-boggling
because he had some annotations there
that are really only modern like today's
standard it's really really great I
checked some of this and if you go over
that with an engine the engine says the
same thing sometimes it's remarkable
maybe they maybe he reworked that like
in the 1990s or 2000s nas and died in
2010 and I'm not mistaken I think it
should be on the back cover 2010 yeah
maybe he uses a computer like to read
recheck his things I don't know it's
fantastic it's fantastic quality of
annotations and Nas and again is a very
inspirational player so this is also one
of my favorite books absolutely another
all-time favorite book and this was
recently mentioned somehow in one of my
one of my live shows is this one bye-bye
Donna the king some people think it's
the best chance book ever written
maybe it is I don't know it's really
fantastic Donna was a very controversial
figure in or some dutch Grandmaster for
many years one of the best Dutch players
and he was a very prolific writer this
is basically a collection of his chess
pieces means his chess writings articles
in newspapers for chess magazine and so
on now if you go through this you
basically see you let's say there is a
game or there's some article and it has
attached like this published in frying
fry in Netherland yeah 1971 and so on
had Donna was a fantastic writer very
witty very pointed he was again very
controversial yeah with his views on
many many things you don't have to
necessarily agree though - you have to
just enjoy the process it's really like
fantastically written and he has some of
the most entertaining articles written
on chairs ever so this is a fantastic
book I don't know if you actually can
get it
nowadays I don't know this is a couple
of years Oh Donna died 1988 if I'm not
mistaken mr. - yeah 1988 so this is
obviously these are order articles so
and this has been released more than
once it's a fantastic book and then we
come to an additional thing that I
wanted to often mention that this is
basically a four-part if you want the
series of books written by Guinness of
song called the former editor main
editor of new HS he has written those
four books about chess players this is
not about games
if you
into the books there is not a single
chest diagramming there it's just text
and he started I think with the reliable
past that was I think the first book
that he wrote and this is a bit older I
think that which is not should be from
2000 or so 2003 and he is writing about
about chess players that he knew
fantastically written if you don't get
the first book you have from like Max
but euro of yak watch or 70th birthday
Tony miles yeah sound of no one who felt
yeah this was the first book then then
there was Russian silhouettes
maybe this merciful school actually this
was the first book I'm sorry and this
was the second one
Russell silhouettes is about him about
the Russian players opposite and about
and great soccer is a fantastic writer
then he had this one smart ship from
Saint Petersburg
this is amongst others about again Rick
chicken fajitas this is a legendary
player from st. Petersburg that I that I
did not know personally but played many
blitz games against he was playing very
actively on the ICC for some years much
of that assault Sawaya
this is Cosmo yeah if you want to enjoy
writings about shares about players its
stories its stories and it is there's a
lot about life in the Soviet Union yes
it's really interesting for people and
just interested in history as well and
the fourth book is this one the world
champions
you guys a song call this is obviously
about the world champions
and there are some some great things in
things by um things by about kappa
blanka for example he did not meet kappa
blanka but he had a long interview with
kappa Blancas widow and i mean this is
this is just pure gold and what you what
you're doing there it's great stuff so
this is just like some some older books
that i enjoy about chess history and not
just about them about about the game in
terms of you know how to play the game
but to enjoy the heritage of chess so
now let's have a look at some books that
are like pure hardcore chess of today
I'm going to start with three books that
are about about the middle game mostly
middle endgame or let's say general
chess improvement not about the opening
we will have some opening books after
that I'm going to start with those two
lettuce art because they are it's a tool
it's a two piece so to say yeah the
first book here and one you too as you
see this is written by Constantine
Sakaya and Constantine lambda two very
prolific chess
teachers nowadays in Russia they are
both yeah very well whatever they're
very well-equipped of course with with
exercise positions and showing yeah good
examples of positional chess
what is that all about if you look at
the books they are technically they are
almost identical how they are
constructed so if we go to them go to
the to the contents page they have 30
chapters and it's thinks about like
let's say space adventures problem of
exchanges developing the initiative
coordination and peace activity some
some general subjects what I like about
the books they are really really nicely
researched in terms of selection of
examples the exercise of the game
selected are really really great what is
a little bit difficult I think is how it
is structured as you see here they they
do it in a way maybe I should do it like
that they they let's say yeah that's
number 20 and they they choose a game
and they show show that point sometimes
it's also good the position let's say
they have a star these are full games
because of this about the like if you do
here and I can be linear position you
have they have the middle game position
but you cannot use it as a puzzle book
because the solution is directly or the
the main moves are directly below that
so it's not like okay let's look at five
positions and then at the end yeah check
the solutions this is really excellent
if you prepare lessons for other people
this is why I use the books quite a lot
to find good sample positions to show
certain things in essence if you do it
on your own you cannot use it as a
puzzle book so much the second book is
this is the same thing I never yeah one
position and they they show the
instructive points right after that so
you can definitely learn things but it's
not like it's not a workbook where you
yeah sit sit there and look through the
positions and try to solve them they are
very very well selected though so I
think those are both excellent books and
very much recommended it's um it's lots
of material by the way like 300 pages
each the second
book I think it's a little bit in some
ways more interesting because it has
more non classical examples and not and
not against using old material at all
but sometimes you have things in there
if you are very well-read and chest you
know that half of the games I don't know
how to the games but it's like a huge
portion and here there are one new
example so this is make sense so that
you don't have everything like or you
see things that you'd already a very
nice book by the way is this one the
newest book of chess improvement what is
this all about
if you you then you in chess magazine
you know that they have tons of
annotated games by the players
themselves so the annotate their own
games and over the years and you in
chess magazine had a know is around for
a long time
thirty years and for a long time and
there's a huge amount of great annotated
games so what they did you in this book
they look through all the annotated
games and sorted them into themes this
is very nice to have for example like
here pawn structure the cards would die
to be the hanging pawns the double pawns
some opening structures and so on and
for those let's say if we take let's say
this gets used while they're in the
storm water page 159 they have games
like here short against Tim our notes by
Tim on from 1987 I think there is a
check this right on and new colleges in
there from the bike and the tournament
2004 every single one they have some key
lessons this is really nice so some some
bullet points per game so I think this
is
nice very nice material yeah very
instructive games very well entertain it
and you can sometimes really use it as I
just did like okay is there a pawn
structure that you'd like to learn about
and you can can use it it's good stuff
it's really good stuff I mean it is
mostly we have to admit recycling of
what the head in the magazine but who
has all the magazines and can actually
yeah look through all of them and find
out what is instructive for this
particular subject or not so this is a
really really nice book okay next we
have some opening books yeah and let's
let's grab them it's quite a bunch it's
quite a bunch and for this I will use
the chest forward a little bit more so
let's have a look at let's start let's
do this at the end I'm going to start
with those two here the complete French
advance and the sidestep sister let's do
the complete French advance first and
this is a book about the advance
Frenchness for those who don't
immediately know what I'm talking about
I'm going to put it on the board just a
second so that once French is is this
fire and the absolutely well the most
well-respected expert on the French
advance variation is the initiation
cough and this is the author of this
book together with his son Vladimir
especially Kaufman's also a strong
player I think his Seagram was I think
his the Internet
do we have that on the back cover
yeah he said I am yeah something both of
them they could have collaborated on
that book so we have to say that or we
have to add him that there has been a
book on the advanced French by him
especially cause some years ago and this
is basically an updated version of that
we have some intro chapters that are
about the general the general strategic
ideas about the opening actually
especially calm uses lots of old
materials like if you ever came back
Oracle from 1620 oh my god powers
against floods from 1879 so he uses some
old material to illustrate things and
it's a lot about the strategy involved
of the of the advanced French and I
think the advanced friend just made me
the strategic the most complex line in
the French and he does a good job of
explaining things
it is something probably the book to get
if you want some material on this
opening I don't think there's anything
else remotely comparable about the
advanced French then once French has one
distinct advantage over other lines if
you start and you look at the starting
position of the French if you play 93 or
92 black selects the line they can
choose now a huge range of possibilities
so here there is Bishop before and
there's an idea of six plus the caption
which is only two entirely different
positions
the only positions that are completely
or the only cases where white is
immediately defining the pawn structure
is the advanced French where you will
get most likely the scenario or the
exchange
Church yeah which also immediately
defines the structure of course the
advanced French is the more ambitious of
the two and if you look for an ambitious
line against the French defense this is
probably the way to go
I'm currently working on a knee for base
repertoire myself I now consider the
French advance the only thing that made
me not choosers it's not the quality of
the line but the complexity of it and I
felt I mean publishing something that is
not three hundred or two hundred eighty
page book I felt I cannot do it in the
confinements of what I'm going to
publish but especially call from has 280
pages there to to get to the point so
it's a great book if you want to play
five against the French let's put that
aside and check the other one here the
side self system and this is a book that
I also like and I have to admit that I
have studied it a bit but I have to
yeah study it more because I want to
play this line and I couldn't really get
look at all the details of the vine that
are also interested in the sort of
variation the reason why I'm choosing
this is because it is excellently
research I looked at some of the lines
and it's a fantastic amount of work has
gone into it is written by course mean
web the well-known chess teacher and
coach and I think this is the book about
the side set I think they has been a
book some years ago by
Johansson the Norwegian Grandmaster but
this is like years old and this is from
from late 2016 if I'm not mistaken or
early seventeen I think they have 16
years if you want to play the side set
which is arguably maybe the most
ambitious slide in the remain line this
is the book to get there's nothing
negative to say about it it's a really
hardcore putting book of course and it
starts on 9 p.m. in the side set for
those of you who I should probably put
it on the board I'm sorry about that the
sides have starts exactly as the brayer
does on with 9 of the wave so we are
talking about this position where now
the side set is B should be 798 being
the Braille what we have to really say
about this book is this is almost I
would say for professionals or really
really strong players it starts on line
you know it doesn't tell you anything
about what happens before like when
there's a exchange we the tons of other
lines and the book simply does not
feature that it's not a complete
repertoire at all but if you want to
let's say expand and go to the side so
it's the book you get it's just the best
book about any um let's have a look at
something else I'm going to show you a
book that is not well known in or but
it's pretty nice
this one the hyperaccelerated dragon by
raja pan jovani Raja
pavani are probably not pronounced as
correcting is a Canadian International
Master with Indian roots but it's a this
is a nice book it's by thinkers
publishing no no
publishing company yet and it's about
the HyperX a little dragon I should put
it on the board yeah this is someone
some obscure is wrong but it's certainly
not as well-known as as many many many
other opening so it's putting this on
the board so this is about this opening
the early g6 here in the Sicilian my g6
this is the hyper accelerated dragon
this is usually called accelerated
dragon because black dolls g6 very early
on and the hyper is on the move - so
it's the yeah the most accelerated
dragon and why the hyperaccelerated
dragon the reason is that here why it
has be should be five and many black
players like to avoid that line there's
no real reason to why did it's not like
it's terrible for black but this is like
nowadays almost the main continuation
and if you can make g6 work let's say it
just saves you lots of your effort to
learn something against Bishop e5 they
go here and now the main features of the
book with Amarok see point and the lines
after Knight c3 what I like about this
book a lot is that and this is a huge
difference to many other books the
author is suggesting tons really tons of
new ideas that he has analyzed
extensively with the computer and you
feel like he really put in lots of work
well some books you think ok they just
did a database dump and and
some odd line but it's not an original
work and this feels like an original
work for example the line that and you
absolutely nothing about is this one
here after this the author suggests the
move a six which I never had seen before
and it seems to be quite playable I'm
quite quite amazing yes b5 sometimes
they even play you 6 years so there's
some completely new ideas it's a I only
have nothing negative to say about the
book the only thing that you sometimes
have with them with newer companies
publishing companies like this you think
is publishing sometimes I feel like I
look at the book layout you know she
should see it's not very tidy you know I
think it's sometimes a little bit tricky
to read and sometimes the prose the
language is could have done with some
improvement but it's nothing it's
nothing major if you just care about the
pure chairs it's great that's the one
moment where I think okay this promise
should have been checked by a native
speaker and I know what I'm talking
about
I've written a book in English which is
not my native language and I sometimes
wish that I could have expressed myself
a little bit more fluently and once in a
while yeah this is a little bit rough
language was it is a really nice book
what you should see is why this is worth
while opening to study and something
that's not so well known if you have a
good night against the bureaucracy point
and he suggests some interesting lines
that I have not yet considered the form
is nothing was better and he
actually agrees but anyway if you look
at the moon 1c form you can actually
play this move and the only thing then
one can try again sir sisters which is a
real try for an advantage is to go into
into the Roxy by tear this way and if
you know something good against that
they have a ready-made repertoire
against 93 where you can play c5 and RC
for you go g6 on c4 you play c5 and if
they go over here which is the most
ambitious move you can go with your six
so having a good line in the Roxy is
meaning means that you have a good line
against c4 or 93 it's at least the base
of which a good line against those
openings so the next two books I'm very
start with this one the e3 poison book
certainly the book with the coolest
cover that you can get what is this all
about
III poison by XL Smith Smith is a
grandmaster from Sweden and this is the
second book the first book that he that
he wrote was pump up you're writing a
silly name good book this is a second
this is an opening book and it's about
openings that involved early III I
should show some things to get you more
acquainted what is all the power we're
talking about things like that that it's
very much independent of concrete booth
orders this is about setups
he usually he has many many chapters for
different kind of
setups and possibilities where you could
use III somewhere this for example is
directed against oops against the
Greenfeld where this e3 e4 move now
gives the night without something to
capture on c3 so like actually has to go
back this has a very good reputation for
what by the way so d5 is more or less
defect with this particular move order
this book even features and now it gets
obscured the move III one that looks
really small yeah but here you show some
interesting ideas after you 5 you go can
go c4 and you have an English with e3
and setups like that it's all very very
creative interesting material for
normally four players even the before
player could find some things in there
because there are actually some
variations that I care for example that
one of southern transpose into e4
territory of Makia we reach the panel
callosum very remarkable there is um
there are some huge upsides about this
book and some downside then the upside
is it's full of original ideas so it's a
book that I personally like a lot
because I can basically you can open it
up and find something interesting there
are many interesting order wrinkles and
ideas that I had not considered yet for
example I used some line of this book in
a game when I played III the idea is
that after night of 64 black probably
would have to play one of the parts
after c6 white gets an interesting Slav
without default that's quite interesting
or they go is six when you go III and
with the commitment of six this Queens
fianchetto the Queen said you cannot
make some quite a lot of sense it's at
least a playable position so for I think
for stronger players there are many
interesting ideas that can be used in
particular application area well in
single games as surprise weapons or as
additions to your repertoire
it is however it's such it's full of
ideas but it is also completely
unstructured if you go into them if you
go into the contents page it's it's
really difficult to find something I
mean he has some things here like entire
Queens gambit accepted then the Queens
gambit accepted it's very difficult to
find stuff yeah it's very difficult I
think I read the revenue by Matthew
Sadler and UHS magazine about the book
and he gave it two stars out of five
because he said that's probably a good
book in there but I cannot find anything
which is kind of agree somewhat but I
wouldn't give two stars and I think I
would give it four because I still like
the original content but be aware I
think this is mostly for stronger
players who are able to kind of digest
the we have the different orders and
kind of pick out people pick out what
they like and can use but it can be
extremely irritating for me let's say
the 17 1800 player I guess because it is
it's so full of different things you
kind of feel you read you read a lot but
it didn't understand much so it's it
feels like it feels a bit unorganized
but I mean I've written books and/or
like one book and many other
publications it's with this subject it's
very difficult to do
so I kind of I kind of understand what
is how it is but I think it's difficult
to do better but it's a very interesting
book I think I like the concept quite a
lot some of those move orders are really
poisonous you can get people into and do
things they have never seen before
exactly I'm just I'm just going to give
you one example so this is an invitation
to the to the bank of government or the
one Benoni what about this move this is
not very aggressive of course but what
did where does it lead to
yeah black could do this and play d5
this is all of a sudden upon off Kawika
a completely different opening maybe the
black player has no clue about it it's
actually rather likely because the
combination all been known you have the
comic-con is not very usual
so what could black do when I looked at
this opening and this desire for black
in my banker gambit repertoire I thought
gee 6 is good it is good of course 93
Bishop g7 and then defined this is what
Smith recommends going to the Pannonia
tempo with his fries and you know this
cannot be the greatest Bologna ever and
it is it where is the tempo down it
cannot be super great but it is a
different opening yeah if the black
player intended to play the bank oh he
just C now has to play the benoni
I was actually once had this on the
board once and I mean I haven't
extra-careful under Bologna but it was
an opening that had
plate once and it's not so easy to do
so oftentimes they this book presents
you waste to trick your opponent into
something that they don't know about
that well the next book and this is one
that I recommend like fully does this
one playing d45 the classical repertoire
by QWERTY chess by Nicholas Tillis
notice prolific and well respected
author he's some rated like 2100 or so I
think it's not he's not as strong super
strong over the ball player but he has
been a second to many top grandmasters
because his realm respected opening the
research and expert also on databases
computer analyst and so on this is if I
know third or fourth book I think he was
written to a two or three in
collaboration with our God and he has
written the e45 book last year and this
is now 225 so it's a classical
repertoire means we're talking about him
45
I don't think looking at the actual book
can help you that much so I will show
you some some of the things that he has
in the book he's recommending two on
city 45 and he has a full repertoire
here even involving this this some other
of peaches Queen's Queen porn lines the
the main meat of it is however the
classical Queen's Gambit and he does
recommend to plain like this and now the
exchange variation the carts put
structure he's got very nice
recommendations again said involving
this night aged five lines we're talking
about about about this this idea h6
first actually
this is this this is nowadays very very
respected for black and he does a good
job of presenting that in the absolute
main line maybe maybe this is the
midnight I don't know if the Queen's
candidate it's tough to say but in the
in the absolute classical main line here
with Bishop g5 he is recommending to
play with 9b d7 and then go for c5 in
most cases I think he inserts this move
and then go for c5 this is how kramnik
plays us nowadays this is actually quite
good fruit like I mean black seems to be
very okay there some of them some
positions are a little bit difficult to
win but it's yeah it's very sound very
solid that's what you get out of D 45 he
is got a very interesting recommendation
in the Queen's Gambit with Bishop f4 in
the bishop and four line he plays this
this in b6 which is actually very
competitive it's very fighting for both
so also very interesting the only
recommendation that I am NOT a huge fan
of I think it's it's a good opening line
absolutely but I definitely would have
done something else I mean with those
lines I can easily imagine myself
recommending that against the Catalan
yes he has recommended to capture me and
play a six this is a good line
absolutely and maybe one of the tough
tests of the Catalan but if you go for a
classical repertoire I think you should
have gone with B should be several like
there should be seven line it's this is
the classical platinum this is not a
criticism based on the line is bad or
anything I just think that it would have
been a more fitting choice this is
somewhat this is quite a bunch of theory
to learn
and it's it's very interesting I think
it's one of the best parts of the book
another thing that selection itself is
not extremely fitting so I still
recommend it if you want to go d45 great
stuff and now I want to show you two
books that I don't recommend just as a
word of warning and because they are not
there and at least one of the books has
been really successful and I think oh my
god so let's start with this one this is
a book that I feel you should avoid it's
called the Thea Quito solution by name
on and choker to others which is one
problem yeah
they present a repertoire based on g6
with black and g3 with white so it's
white and black the problem is of the
whole book is it's a mess it's a
complete mess it's unstructured you have
ideas left and right you don't find
anything I mean this is like if you
criticize you III poison book this is
like five times worse you don't find
anything and the main problem is that
then which is simply astounding that
that this happens is there are things in
the book I mean there we have two
authors there are some lines that they
have in the book I show you one they
have this line in the book yeah which
for ages is known to be just better for
white
it is better for what there's simply no
way around that
and they present that line don't give
any improvement and then there are
there's a there's one point I could
actually find that if I'm looking where
it's in the text like what of the
Shocker says and this is interesting you
can play that and the other author in
brackets says okay this is my statement
this line is totally bad you should play
it ever so you have contradicting views
in this I really don't think I've ever
seen this happen in a book I mean you
should i completely okay with
recommending two things for example I
already say yeah this is a more
strategic approach this is a bit sharper
but both I mean it should be okay and
they should be I mean they should form
one opinion about it if I can recommend
it or not in some case in this in the
slide for example they don't improve an
existing theory and the existing theory
is just terrible for black so I don't
get that they have some lines in there
that are just bad I mean and easily
refuted sometimes I can just look up
common knowledge let's say this is for
me a total no-go in the book you cannot
give things that are just bad and and
it's totally crazy to give a line and
then in brackets the other also says you
you know I don't think this is any good
and the sisters terrible you cannot do
that the other thing that I completely
don't understand this with white and
with black they go g6 against everything
and with white they don't go to three
but actually play Knight f3 because
somehow they feel they should prevent me
five okay but then if you look at the
further recommendation they actually
allow a five here and play King's Indian
verse where it is well known than white
I mean why does rather slightly worse of
anything else I mean you've never having
anything the extra tempo is meaningless
and in some cases black is actually
happy - yeah - to have not played and if
for example stop playing an f6 well
there's the well-known idea for example
with age five years they think they
don't show anything
I guess it's those ideas it just it just
I don't get it
and especially I was very disappointed
that they don't go g3 on one because
this is actually quite interesting in
some cases for example if black plays
let's say d5 is some stuff like that it
makes a lot of sense to not play this
because this this and this without this
night having played is actually quite
interesting you can sometimes play
listen one move only can play the 90
year so there are many interesting
points to one g3 another one being then
after c5 you can transpose into a
Sicilian with g3 where you don't have
played 93 and this year is quite
interesting sometimes called the polar
bear Henrietta Nelson this is an
interesting opening for it I mean but
they don't give that they just give the
Kings Indian attack let's say in
versions where is completely toothless
for example like him okay you have to
play before simply the only move that is
some some kind of try for advantage the
guru felt with what I completely hate
this bouquet I'm sorry I don't see yeah
I think it's unusable it just just weird
- weird selections and then you have two
authors arguing what's good and what's
not that idea of the book I think it's
quite good yeah place it on the Kings in
Canada but I don't get it so what is one
the next book I also thoroughly disliked
is this
my first chest opening repertoire from
black they're ready to go package for
ambitious beginners by Vincent Millay
why do I don't like that book I don't
like it because the selection of knives
is weird it's supposed to be for
ambitious beginner so we're talking
about what I said
1,400 1,500 it's always tough to say
little fishes beginner means I'm going
to show you what he suggests and okay
the first line is like what what to do
in years before his suggestion is to
play the Scandinavian with Knight f6
okay objectively speaking this is a
slightly questionable opening line on a
higher level on an amateur level it's
okay okay so you can you can play that I
don't have a huge problem with this
recommendation actually it leads to half
open play it's not what I would
recommend but it's it's something that
you can do he however he spends lots of
time on analyzing the most vexing lines
yeah yeah with the disc and with lines I
don't know if this is appropriate for a
beginner or an ambitious beginner to to
look at stuff like that I'm kind of
endow it to be honest I think this is a
bit more a bit too complicated maybe and
something simpler is more advisable I
don't know but this is not the biggest
issue that I have I mean this is kind of
a thing still think something that you
can do but against deform it gets it
gets hard yeah so he wants to go d5 and
he recommends Alvin's counting gambit
and I don't see any point of reckon
ending an opening that is almost
unplayable if one knows a little bit
yeah it's just a bad opening and I know
its ambitious beginners and if you play
that against the 1500 with black they
probably don't know what they're doing
with white but still why would you
recommend something that is so easily
reviewed at you know something I mean
against this let black it's just worse
against this black is worse is worth
against anything and if you get on on
the sword decent level people will
prepare that I mean for example if you
look at the level of 16 1700 if you are
on any Youth Championships for example
where where the kids are actually
prepared if someone plays the Albin's I
just I mean I can I cannot stop laughing
yeah I would just you know ten minutes
there and you refute there was the whole
thing it's just it's just bad so I don't
understand why why do I recommend
something that is actually not good I
mean if you want to get too quirky piece
play you can maybe are you remember why
not the children
that is at least not terrible on go with
the Queens gambit accepted needs to open
play as well and is pretty easily
learned and then you can play that for
your whole chess career while the
husbands you have to ditch I know
someone someone you will know mention
llamo Rosa which play it yeah and some
lines 20 years ago if you would play
nowadays you would just lose probably
have the other game okay this is one
problem but the second thing and this is
this just this I was kind of really
speechless about okay people can do this
of course and now you don't play the
Alvin's anymore this is a problem from
the repertoire point of view anyway but
okay so your chairs offer you somehow
show the
show the L burns and now we have to
present something here so what would you
choose I mean I would choose this one
for example because this is somewhat
related to the Alban sir and it's a
Chico and of course but it's just a
subset of lines and it's relatively
easily learned what I would say let's
say Knight f6 and then play the Queens
gambit accepted which is now here white
doesn't have before it's easily learned
so there are some lines even Bishop a5
is kind of okay here if you want offbeat
instead he recommends to play a stone
wall so he goes he sings and then he
wants to play the story like against
anything and I mean after this black is
just in terrible shape
I mean this is almost unplayable on any
level
I know it's beginner level or post
beginner level but right would you
recommend something that is known to be
bad he actually chose this line and
doesn't have any improvement he just has
no km that is gross whatever or he gives
some sudden line that says this is
interesting I mean it may be interesting
but it's also bad so I don't see the
point like if bad lines if there are
good lines available of course you can
say in some cases you can argue on a
certain level a different type of line
could be helpful for developing your
chest for example if you show gambit
lines to kids this is something that I
feel is kind of ok enough for example
let's say and you would show somebody
lines with this like gambit will see 3
or or play let's say the Evans gambit
which is a respect of an opening
this is something that may be at a later
stage you have to replace with something
but to say for kids to play something
active and they should learn technics
okay but why go for yeah this is played
quite often for the for a bad stone wall
of all openings which is not technical
at all and it's just strategically quite
dubious and just in this company move
order so I just don't get it I don't get
it why I recommend bad lines so I would
avoid that book I think the white the
white book here is better I think those
lines are more I think suited for kids
especially this is this I don't
understand so yeah two books I disliked
many books I liked in general what you
have to say nowadays the the the quality
of books has improved greatly yeah you
can still buy or can meet occasional
real stinker of a book but lots of books
are great I hope I've given you some
good recommendations it's a bit late for
to have them on the under the Christmas
tree but I think most people buy the
books themselves so I think lots of
things to look to look at I hope you
enjoyed this all of you and I hope you
all have a good Christmas days and it
would start for 2018 thanks a lot